l'une des conséquences les plus
tragiques de l'erreur médicale dont a
été victime Guillaume gaillard c'est
qu'il ne peut plus exercer son métier de
conducteur de train sa grande passion je
suis arrivé à la conduite des trains
c'était une vocation et j'ai été nommé
conducteur de train au minimum de l'âge
que l'on peut avoir à l'époque c'était
21 ans voilà pour mes 20 ans non j'étais
conducteur de tram
c'est la première fois que Guillaume
revient dans sa gare tous les jours il
empruntait ce chemin pour rejoindre sa
locomotive aujourd'hui il faut se rendre
à l'évidence c'est au-dessus de ses
forces
ça essouffe ça fait souffrir c'est
vraiment une distance importante c'est
une distance que je faisais tous les
jours pour venir travailler dans la
garde Rambouillet mais maintenant ça
devient vraiment quelque chose de
compliqué
il y a encore peu de temps ce train qui
arrive en gare c'est Guillaume qui le
conduisait
que devient-on lorsque ceux qui doivent
prendre soin de nous nous blesse
lorsque ceux qui doivent préserver notre
vie la menace
chaque jour chaque année des hommes et
des femmes sont victimes d'erreurs
médicales combien sont-ils plusieurs
centaines plusieurs milliers peut-être
plus
j'ai décidé de rencontrer deux d'entre
eux
Eric
[Musique]
et Guillaume
deux hommes dont la vie a basculé
uniquement parce qu'un jour ils ont
voulu guérir
[Musique]
je suis Guillaume gaillard j'ai 44 ans
et je suis la malheureuse victime d'une
erreur médicale
je m'appelle Eric Cano j'ai 42 ans et je
m'estime victime d'une erreur médicale
chaque année en France
de 13 millions de personnes sont
hospitalisées
si dans la très grande majorité des cas
les soins se déroulent sans souci
parfois la situation dérape et la vie
des victimes basculent pour toujours
c'est le cas d'Eric et de Guillaume
[Musique]
un hypermarché dans une zone commerciale
parmi les nombreux clients un homme se
promène avec un mouchoir blanc sur le
nez
c'est terrible canaux un contrôleur des
finances de 42 ans
et très sec
donc c'est très agressif pour moi
et je supporte pas quoi ça m'a vraiment
très mal en plus j'ai une sensation de
comment dire de vie d'être froid dans
les poumons c'est très agressif pour moi
donc
d'une manière générale quand je pèse
dans les rayons frais mon hiver je mets
l'écharpe
mais là au printemps où elle était ben
c'est soit un mouchoir soit un masque
bon on me regarde un peu bizarrement
mais bon
c'est pas le choix
les courses sont chênes dans des rayons
interminablesment longs pour Eric c'est
le moment le plus pénible au repos il
est en situation d'hyperventilation
alors poussez un caddie rempli de course
tout en marchant sur des centaines de
mètres c'est un petit exploit
je suis une pause là parce que j'ai
souffert
quand je fais une marche dans un magasin
où
après en ville moi ça me rappelle
l'époque où j'étais valide où je faisais
des randonnées et je m'entais je montais
des pompes comme ça au Mercantour quoi
alors que je fais que mes courses
[Musique]
mon métier aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer
de vivre voilà donc d'essayer de vivre
c'est de se lever pour maintenir une
présence assemblant de vie mais alors
tout le reste vous me délester tout le
reste parce que vivre mais vivre de la
manière la plus basique qui soit ah bah
c'est déjà c'est 90% de mon temps quoi
voilà
pour Eric tout a commencé avec une
maladie très banale il y a 7 ans
j'ai quelques épisodes on va dire dans
l'année de sinusite el rhinopharyngite
qui m'embête toi voilà donc je vais
consulter un ORL local cette Earl là 20
aiguillé vers un de ses confrères
ensuite pour faire une chirurgie je me
dis que je sois entouré de gens
compétents qui savent ce qu'ils vont
faire c'est les médecins sont des savons
donc non je suis parfaitement confiant
je me dis que il va me débarrasser de
mon petit souci puis qu'après la vie la
vie est belle quoi
Eric accepte de se faire opérer le
médecin réalise alors une turbinectomie
c'est à dire une ablation des cornets
nasaux dont la fonction est de filtrer
et d'humidifier l'air
il s'agit d'une opération courante
pratiquée près de 10 000 fois chaque
année en France mais quelques semaines
plus tard
Eric ne se sent toujours pas mieux au
contraire le mot au fil des semaines
ensuite
je ne sens pas d'amélioration
je refais même une sinusite derrière je
vais revoir ce chirurgien pour lui dire
monsieur ça ne fonctionne pas je vais de
plus en plus mal il me propose à ce
moment-là de
faire ce coup-là une intervention sur un
cornet moyen donc pour soi-disant me
déboucher le nez
puis enlève tous ces cornets
suite à ces deux premières chirurgies
mon état c'est
progressivement mais inexorablement
dégradé donc au niveau douleur au niveau
fatigue aussi face à ces
deux études de changer d'ORL il cherche
désespéré
ment je finis par retourner en région
parisienne
où je rencontre un chirurgien qui
se propose de faire l'intervention cette
fois-ci sur les sinus puisqu'il pense
que mes infections répétées sont dues au
manque de ventilation des sinus donc il
me fait bonne impression si ça y est je
suis enfin tombé sur la personne qu'il
faut je crois qu'il a compris mon
problème il propose quelque chose cette
opération est censée améliorer l'état du
quadragénaire mais Eric va plonger un
peu plus dans son mal-être
et là très vite en quelques mois là mais
j'ai dégringolé le porte qui me restait
ce sont les vanille quoi j'étais
vraiment à bout
c'était même plus une fatigue j'étais
dans un état d'épuisement et avec des
douleurs mais vraiment intolérable quoi
alors qu'il devrait normalement être
guéri
Eric se sent de plus en plus mal
lorsqu'il consulte de nouveau les
spécialistes sont perplexes on est
incapable de naître un mot ou des mots
sur cette maladie là voire pire
on me dit ou des fois j'ai rien ou
pourquoi pas sous l'aspect faiblesse que
j'aurais une maladie un peu
psychosomatique qu'en gros il faut que
j'oublie mon nez voilà que je pense que
je prends ça à travailler des choses
comme ça
mais de quelques mois il doit se rendre
à l'évidence
quand on travaille plus voilà on sent
bien qu'on fait plus partie de la
société donc moi quand j'ai été obligé
de demander le travail c'est vraiment au
bout de course et quand je n'en pouvais
plus d'épuisement et de douleur il faut
savoir que les derniers mois ce que j'ai
pas manqué de courage soit je peux vous
l'assurer les derniers mois les
collègues voyaient que ça à l'époque
façon fallait pas être devant
me trouver à des bureaux vides pour
essayer de me faire dormir enfin dormir
ne me faire reposer un petit peu parce
que je n'en pouvais plus quoi donc dans
ces moments là je me disais mais je vais
pas pouvoir faire ça pendant des années
quoi c'est pas jouable voilà j'ai
effectivement j'ai un jour voilà j'ai eu
ma meilleure collègue j'écoute voilà je
vais pas revenir je peux plus je suis au
bout de au bout de ce que je pouvais
faire quoi et donc effectivement je suis
pas revenu donc là je suis un arrêt
depuis plus d'un an si Eric ne comprend
toujours pas l'origine de ces douleurs
il commence suspecter un lien avec ses
opérations chirurgicales mais s'agit-il
vraiment d'une erreur médicale
Daniel Bernard Puech vous êtes avocate
et vous défendez notamment des victimes
d'erreurs médicales donc quelles
circonstances considère-t-on qu'on est
victime d'une erreur médicale alors on
peut considérer qu'on est victime d'une
erreur médicale quand on sent qu'il y a
un problème par exemple quand on est
rentré pour une infection
bénigne dans une clinique et qu'on en
ressort avec un préjudice beaucoup plus
important ou que on est rentré pour un
préjudice important mais qu'on en
ressort avec un préjudice aggravé
Serge Eiffel vous êtes psychiatre
sont-elles prises en compte ces erreurs
les erreurs médicales c'est un peu
difficile de les prendre en compte
d'abord parce que la médecine n'est pas
une science tout à fait exacte qu'on
peut admettre que un médecin chirurgien
se trompe que après on peut interpréter
de mille façons une intervention qui
s'est mal passée ou qui a mal tourné et
puis il y a beaucoup de solidarité aussi
dans le corps médical par rapport à par
rapport à ça et donc les victimes se
sent doublement victimes parce qu'elles
ont l'impression en plus de ne pas être
entendu ne pas être reconnu de se
heurter à une espèce de plafond de verre
ou voilà elles sont seules un peu contre
le reste du monde il y a le corps
médical qui en général sert un petit peu
les coudes et eux qui se sentent tout à
fait isolés et rejeté et incompris
incompris
ericano à la sensation de l'être le
corps médical semble ignorer l'origine
de ces symptômes alors qu'il continue à
souffrir il n'a qu'une certitude sa vie
ne sera plus jamais la même rendu
partiellement invalide il va désormais
devoir compter sur ses parents
[Musique]
allez
viens allez on y va c'est parti comme
tous les jours à 8h20 Guillaume gaillard
conducteur de train emmène son fils
Mathis à l'école
souvent quand je rencontre des des gens
qui germent mon dossier je leur dis ma
vie est fichue mais non c'est bon la vie
est belle mais ils vivent pas ce que je
vis
tous les matins c'est comme ça tous les
matins je l'accompagne jusqu'au point de
la rue parce que il reste pas grand
chose il reste
70 mètres mais 70 mètres c'est 70 mètres
c'est
des difficultés et puis c'est à la
longue ça devient compliqué ça fait ça
fait vraiment c'est pas agréable voilà
je surveille quand même si il arrive
c'est voilà ça s'ouvre
[Musique]
aller-retour
on peut dorénavant parcourir dans une
journée
tout ça à cause d'une erreur médicale
survenue il y a 2 ans
cours d'un voyage en Italie pour les
vacances sur le bord d'une rivière j'ai
je me suis tordu la cheville ça m'a fait
une bonne entorse
à mon retour en France vu que j'avais
énormément de douleurs je suis allé voir
mon médecin traitant il m'orient
directement à l'hôpital et on a
découvert au final que en plus de la
double entorse que j'avais au pied il y
avait un petit arrachement osseux au
niveau de la cheville le médecin
généraliste
dirige à charge pour lui de définir les
soins adaptés à l'arrachement osseux de
Guillaume
compte un chirurgien qui qui prévoit
rapidement une opération pour retirer ce
petit bout de ce qui me crée des
douleurs à mon réveil
j'ai eu d'intense douleur dans le pied
et quand le médecin est arrivé je lui ai
expliqué mon problème comme quoi j'avais
très très mal et que je ressentais plus
la voûte plantaire il m'a chatouillé un
peu le dessous du pied avec un stylo et
en me disant que c'était certainement dû
à l'œdème et que ça laisse dissiper sur
de lui le chirurgien renvoie Guillaume à
son domicile pour suivre sa
convalescence
je rentre à la maison les douleurs c'est
c'est intenable je j'attends une journée
de jours trois jours
on a confiance dans la médecine donc je
me dis ça va passer après quelques jours
sans aucune amélioration
[Musique]
[__] neurologue pour effectuer un
électromyogramme objectif vérifier le
bon fonctionnement des nerfs de son pied
il contrôle muscle la taille Musse la
cuisse le mollet il descend petit à
petit et au niveau de la cheville il y a
une perte totale du de signal et
il constate une liaison une lésion du
nerf pour le spécialiste le sans appel
la voûte plantaire de Guillaume ainsi
que son gros orteil son paralysés
seul explication possible le chirurgien
a raté son opération et a coupé le nerf
commandant les fonctions motrices du
pied
je considère qu'on est même plus dans
l'erreur médicale on est dans
l'incompétence il ne savait pas faire et
il a fait quand même il aurait pas dû
faire il aurait pas dû faire ça
c'est
voilà c'est pire que que l'erreur
médicale que c'est il m'a pas loupé
dans le rapport que Guillaume reçoit
l'expert affirme que le chirurgien a
commis trois fautes pour commencer il a
pratiqué une opération alors que du
repos et des infiltrations auraient pu
être suffisant ensuite il a utilisé le
mauvais outil
enfin il a opéré sans l'aide de caméra
pourtant obligatoire pour intervenir
dans une zone si petite et nervurée
quand on lisse rapport on peut être
révolté on peut être révolté parce que
il est accablant pour le chirurgien
pour Guillaume c'est une nouvelle vie
non seulement il ne peut plus marcher ni
même rester debout longtemps mais en
plus il commence à ressentir des
douleurs fantômes insupportables
[Musique]
tel point
que vient à les rendre supportables le
cheminot est alors contraint de rester
cloîtré chez lui tel un oiseau en cage
on est là on attend
on aimerait faire mais on ne peut pas
faire et c'est vraiment normal on a
vraiment le sentiment d'être inutile
de servir à rien
voilà
c'est inactivité
c'est ce qui a vraiment de plus pesant
ne rien faire ou alors quand on fait ça
fait mal
voilà c'est à vous faut faire la part
des choses faire un petit peu
sans avoir trop mal
condamné à souffrir
à Guillaume gaillard n'a plus le choix
il doit apprendre à vivre avec son
handicap
[Musique]
Serge et fesses vous êtes psychiatre
quelles sont les séquelles qu'on observe
le plus souvent chez les victimes
d'erreurs médicales
l'erreur médicale je crois que c'est
sans doute celle qui crée justement le
statut de victime peut-être le plus fort
parce que ça fait vaciller toute la
confiance qu'on peut avoir dans le monde
autour de soi les gens qui ont fait le
plus confiance en dehors de ses proches
c'est les médecins qui vous soignent et
qui sont là pour vous faire du bien le
le mot d'ordre des médecins c'est primum
notre gérer d'abord ne pas nuire or
justement là il tombe dans quelque chose
qui est tout à fait l'inverse de ce
qu'on peut attendre d'un médecin donc ce
statut de victime c'est pas comme être
victime d'un chauffard ou d'un accident
ou quelque chose comme ça on est victime
de quelqu'un en qui on a placé sa
confiance donc on rentre sans doute
beaucoup plus fortement dans ce statut
de victime dans ce statut d'injustice et
donc il y a comme un basculement
d'identité je suis devenu une victime et
une victime de la médecine
[Musique]
devenu victime depuis son opération des
cornets le quotidien d'ericano est
désormais rythmé par les soins
comme je n'ai plus de muqueuse dans le
nez et dans une grande partie des sinus
le travail va dire du Midi
d'humidification pardon et dépuration
des saletés ne se fait plus c'est-à-dire
que tout stagne à l'intérieur du nez de
la gorge des sinus qui ont des
infections pour prévenir ces infections
eric n'a pas le choix il doit effectuer
des lavements réguliers
mais c'est jamais moins de 5 fois et
puis il y a des jours ça peut être 10 ou
15 fois
d'imaginer avoir une vie sociale
professionnelle avec ça
sans
dire en plus mais voilà c'est pas
glamour quoi donc
le rapport aux autres voyez au bureau
moi je vais enfin j'y allais je vais
toujours pas me faire surprendre parce
que voilà
voilà c'est
soin semble dérisoire face à l'ensemble
des modérés perte du goût et de l'odorat
maux de tête intraitable troubles
neurologiques et cardiaques
hyperventilation la liste est longue
Michel et Jean-Claude sont les parents
d'Éric plusieurs fois par semaine ils
viennent comme aujourd'hui s'occuper de
leur fils l'erreur médicale dont pense
souffrir eric a également bouleversé
leur vie
depuis deux ans quand Eric ne vit pas
chez eux ils viennent s'occuper de lui
et accomplir les tâches ménagères qu'il
ne peut plus faire malgré ses 70 ans
Jean-Claude du jardin pendant que Michel
gère l'intendance les tâches
administratives le lavage et le
repassage
moi j'ai toujours fait confiance en
médecin maintenant je ne le fais plus
confiance même pour moi même pour moi
maintenant je le dis carrément je ne
fais plus confiance au médecin je ne
peux pas je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
il aurait il aurait bien accident de
voiture par exemple de sa faute tout ça
bon ça ne serait pas la même chose mais
là je me dis on l'a est-ce quinté et on
a éclaté toute la famille toute la
famille
[Musique]
conscient du fardeau qui touche sa
famille cette situation d'assister est
un crève-cœur pour Éric
quand je les vois
s'activer pour la maison ménage toutes
ces choses que je ne peux plus faire
ça me fait mal que ça me renvoie ma
propre impuissance et puis je me dis que
c'est voilà c'est pas dans l'ordre des
choses tout simplement quoi c'est
j'aurais jamais aimé je pouvais pas
imaginer ça voilà je pensais que c'est
moi qui aimerait mes parents et puis
voilà c'est l'inverse
la solidarité familiale permet pour
l'instant à Eric de sur
vivre une question inquiète ses parents
comment fera Eric le jour où il ne
seront plus là pour l'aider
Daniel Bernard Puech vous êtes avocate
comment expliquer que les victimes
d'erreurs médicales doivent faire appel
à leurs parents pour les aider
alors moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que dans
l'un des témoignages je n'ai pas vu que
le jeune homme avait eu recours à la
CRCI c'est à dire que les SCI sont des
commissions régionales de conciliation
et d'indemnisation qui ont été créés par
la loi du 4 mars 2002 et qui permettent
gratuitement d'avoir une expertise donc
je dirais que le problème de toutes les
victimes c'est un manque d'information
ou une désinformation et qui est capable
de leur donner ces informations s'ils ne
le savent pas normalement dans chaque
département il y a une maison
départementale du handicap maintenant
qui accorde notamment des allocations
pour tierce personne c'est-à-dire que
les parents qui l'aident peuvent être
remplacés par quelqu'un qui que le jeune
homme périt puisqu'il obtient il devrait
obtenir une prestation de compensation
du handicap
[Musique]
pour ericano si la souffrance physique
est difficile à supporter le plus dur
est de ne pas comprendre l'origine de
ces problèmes
pourtant il va bientôt pouvoir mettre un
nom sur sa maladie
l'une des conséquences les plus
tragiques de l'erreur médicale dont a
été victime Guillaume gaillard c'est
qu'il ne peut plus exercer son métier de
conducteur de train sa grande passion je
suis arrivé à la conduite des trains
c'était une vocation et j'ai été nommé
conducteur de train au minimum de l'âge
que l'on peut avoir à l'époque c'était
21 ans voilà pour mes 20 ans non j'étais
conducteur de tram
c'est la première fois que Guillaume
revient dans sa gare tous les jours il
empruntait ce chemin pour rejoindre sa
locomotive aujourd'hui il faut se rendre
à l'évidence c'est au-dessus de ses
forces
ça essouffe ça fait souffrir c'est
vraiment une distance importante c'est
une distance que je faisais tous les
jours pour venir travailler dans la
garde Rambouillet mais maintenant ça
devient vraiment quelque chose de
compliqué
il y a encore peu de temps
c'est
Guillaume
si on peut considérer ça comme une
double peine
on perd son travail on perd un travail
qui passionnait et qui était intéressant
qui était
j'avais de l'avenir je devais monter au
TGV je vais voilà et puis on est blessé
dans son corps et on est blessé parce
qu'on ne peut plus faire son travail je
pense que ça va être difficile de passer
à autre chose
c'est
c'est une vie c'est une vie qui
disparaît voilà c'était plein de choses
et des collègues des rencontres et c'est
une c'est vraiment une vie qui disparaît
il y a une tradition SNCF c'est on fait
le dernier train
on sait qu'on va s'arrêter c'est le
dernier train c'est une fête c'est tout
ce qu'on je le ferai jamais il y a
jamais eu
conséquence de sa perte d'activité
aujourd'hui la situation financière de
Guillaume est de plus en plus délicate
en arrêt maladie longue durée il touche
encore son salaire de 2000 euros
cependant depuis deux ans il a perdu
l'intégralité des primes liés à son
statut de conducteur de train
voilà perte de prime traction
20216 euros perte d'indemnité de nuit
1848 euros perte d'indemnités de
dimanche est faite 2030 euros perte
d'allocations de déplacement roulant
829 euros
au final l'erreur médicale dont il a été
victime lui a déjà coûté 32350 euros
mon épouse a dû travailler plus pour
gagner plus voilà
mais ça ne compense pas de toute façon
les pertes donc c'est un changement de
vie c'est-à-dire qu'on doit faire plus
attention à toutes nos dépenses on doit
voilà limiter des choses les vacances
les c'est obligatoire sinon on en sort
pas la situation
si la SNCF ne parvient pas à lui trouver
un poste il sera licencié il ne touchera
alors plus que son allocation handicapée
de 759 euros par mois et surtout il sera
isolé
la perte d'emploi est presque une double
peine pour une personne victime d'erreur
médicale d'un point de vue financier
mais aussi social elle le coupe du monde
extérieur comment faire pour que les
victimes d'erreurs médicales ne se
sentent pas seulement sur le plan social
perd son travail cette majeur c'est une
catastrophe sociale familiale conjugale
donc c'est vrai qu'une indemnisation
permet de passer le cap et de compenser
un tout petit peu si vous voulez la
perdre du travail mais si le travail est
devenu impossible
et qu'il y a une inaptitude et qu'il n'y
a pas de possibilité de reclassement
c'est vrai que seul si vous voulez les
indemnisations de perte de gain
permettent à la victime de continuer à
vivre à peu près correctement mais c'est
pas toujours le cas effectivement
[Musique]
à cause de l'erreur médicale dont il a
été victime Guillaume gaillard a dû
abandonner sa passion pour les trains ça
il ne l'accepte pas
il a donc décidé de se battre pour
obtenir réparation
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Musique]
cela fait 6 ans qu'Eric Cano souffre
sans connaître le mal qui le ronge en
2011 un rendez-vous chez un ORL va tout
changer le médecin évoque devant ses
parents et lui un syndrome peu connu
aussitôt rentré la mère d'Éric fait des
recherches
je vais voir ma mère
chez mes parents un soir suite à la
dernière consultation et elle me dit
tiens
et chercher un petit peu sur internet et
j'ai vu un truc ça s'appelle le syndrome
du navire j'ai bien vu que les symptômes
correspondaient pratiquement point par
point et donc quand j'ai commencé à voir
les suites soit des témoignages que je
pouvais trouver sur Internet ou dans des
comptes rendus de journée médicale
je me suis dit mauvaise pioche quoi
ces problèmes il les doit aux opérations
chirurgicales qui la subit pire dans un
cas comme le sien ou la totalité des
cornets a été enlevée une nécrose
pourrait apparaître sur les muqueuses à
vif
[Musique]
je suis conscient je suis triste je sais
maintenant qu'au bout au bout d'une
aggravation continue de la maladie
puisqu'il n'y a pas de raison que ça
s'enraille
c'est des gros problèmes de santé voir
le décès sous une forme ou sous une
autre
ou souffrance rime avec absence de
traitement
eric va alors peu à peu s'enfoncer dans
une profonde dépression
j'ai fait des tentatives du suicide
plusieurs fois
on est en cours de 2002 en 2011
à ce que je parce que je souffrais je
souffrais trop
moralement physiquement
et puis que le monde médical me lâchait
quoi
est-ce que le fait que l'erreur vienne
d'un médecin fait qu'on ne peut plus
faire confiance aux autres médecins ah
bah oui totalement évidemment une fois
que la confiance est trahie et quand on
découvre qu'un ami est menteur après
voilà tout ça ne faut chez lui donc on
peut plus faire confiance au médecin
mais ce qui est ce qui est très fort
chez ses victimes là c'est que comme il
rentre dans ce statut de victime ils
investissent leur corps à travers ça et
que au fond ce qu'ils ont eu le problème
qu'ils ont eu à la jambe le problème
qu'ils ont eu au ventre ou à la tête
devient le centre de leur de leur
univers et de leur préoccupation ce qui
rend après aussi les questions
diagnostiques un peu plus compliquées
parce qu'il y a c'est une véritable
obnubilation sur une partie du corps
alors les médecins après renvoient ils
ont vite fait de renvoyer l'ascenseur en
disant mais ça n'a plus rien à voir avec
de la médecine c'est du psychosomatique
c'est du psychiatrique c'est du
psychologique et après démêler ce qui
relève de effectivement des dégâts
causés par la médecine et de ce
surinvestissement comme ça de du corps
c'est assez compliqué
le matin l'avocate Bénédicte Papin se
renché Eric Cano pour leur premier
rendez-vous une avocate qui se déplace
chez son client c'est rare mais dans le
cas d'Eric elle n'a pas le choix bonjour
monsieur
comment allez-vous on fait aller
ensemble ils vont étudier son dossier et
voir s'ils peuvent vraiment poursuivre
ces médecins
quand je vois ma vie maintenant et que
je repense à toutes ces interventions et
surtout à leurs conséquences
je me dis qu'il y a beau il y a au moins
beaucoup de légèreté et je peux que
Laurent vouloir parce que
si le geste était mauvais bon voilà on
va dire mauvais je pourrais encore le
comprendre si j'avais si je recevais des
excuses et des explications ou si on
prenait ensuite mes douleurs mais
immenses en compte or souvent pas
toujours mais souvent j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de cynisme et ça j'avoue que
c'est très agaçant je pèse mes mots mais
c'est même pire que ça quoi c'est
révoltant quoi purement révoltant au fur
et à mesure de contient l'avocate est de
plus en plus sceptique concernant les
décisions prises par les médecins il
faut opérer si une personne ne répond
pas à un traitement médical qui aurait
pu être prescrit pendant au moins 12
mois et si malgré ce traitement local
bien conduit pendant 12 mois il n'y a
pas de résultats alors il est légitime
de proposer une intervention
chirurgicale d'après ce que vous m'avez
dit vous avez eu des traitements qui
apportaient des effets positifs donc
était-il judicieux de proposer une
intervention chirurgicale alors que vous
aviez des traitements auxquels vous
répondiez parfaitement et qui vous
apportait le soulagement escompté au
cours des quatre crises maximum de
sinusites que vous aviez par an on peut
se poser la question
concernant les opérations chirurgicales
qui ont abouti à rezéquer c'est-à-dire à
supprimer l'intégralité des cornets
d'Héric son avis est tombe peu plus
clair
la littérature médicale nous dit qu'il
faut réserver les cornée pour apporter
un mieux être au patient à hauteur de
50% maximum et que vois-je là sur ce
scanner des vastes fausses nasales
complètement inhabité complètement vide
on est loin des 50 % à aucun moment on
lui a expliqué exactement le geste
technique qui a été réalisé on lui a pas
dit à quoi servait les cornets à quoi
servait les sinus et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on allait les enlever et à quelle
hauteur on allait les enlever la
position de l'avocate est une bonne
nouvelle pour Eric cela le conforte dans
sa quête de vérité
ces chirurgiens voilà j'allais très bien
j'avais une vie parfaitement équilibrée
donc voilà j'ai plus de vie donc il va
falloir mettre des mots et des
responsabilités là dessus
pour avoir une chance de faire
reconnaître ses droits
eric n'a plus qu'une solution il doit
faire appel à des experts médicaux pour
déterminer si une faute a réellement été
commise par les chirurgiens
Daniel Bernard Puech qui sont les
experts médicaux mandatés dans ce genre
de situation il y a trois sortes
d'experts les experts judiciaires qui
sont inscrits auprès des cours d'appel
qui sont nommés par les tribunaux les
soi-disant experts médecins de compagnie
d'assurance qui viendront de toute façon
à l'expertise judiciaire mais qui
défendent la compagnie d'assurance et
les médecins conseillent de victimes
donc l'intérêt d'une victime c'est
d'avoir un expert judiciaire qui n'est
pas affilié à une compagnie d'assurance
et qui présente donc toutes les
garanties d'objectivité qui mènera son
expertise en principe de façon
totalement libre
les experts des compagnies d'assurance
qui sont quelque part jugés partie ils
n'ont aucun intérêt à ce que soit
reconnu une erreur médicale bien sûr
c'est exactement le problème et le
problème en fin de compte des victimes
c'est que dans les dans les dossiers
graves elles sont très vite approchées
par les compagnies d'assurances qui se
présentent comme des anges gardiens de
la victime ce qui n'est pas le cas et
qui de ce fait propose leur médecin leur
propre médecin le problème que ne
connaissent pas du tout les victimes
l'absence d'information c'est de ne pas
savoir que le médecin qui se présente
pour la compagnie bien évidemment n'a
pas la liberté
à l'égard de la victime il est mandaté
par la compagnie payée par la compagnie
depuis deux ans Guillaume gaillard vit
cloîtré chez lui incapable de se
déplacer
pourtant il y a un mois une acquisition
a priori anodine a changé sa vie
[Musique]
ces nouvelles voitures que
j'ai dû m'offrir malheureusement qui est
adapté à ma situation c'est à dire que
j'ai eu l'interdiction de conduire un
véhicule standard et je dois
obligatoirement maintenant avoir une
voiture avec une boîte automatique
mais pour être à nouveau mobile
Guillaume n'a bénéficié
noté 28000 euros un investissement qu'il
ne regrette pas
cette voiture je l'ai attendu longtemps
longtemps puis l'obtenir c'est un peu
une renaissance parce que on peut faire
des choses c'est à dire que
quand quelqu'un
il a pas de voiture il a besoin d'aller
chercher son pain il va chercher son
pain quand quelqu'un il a pas de voiture
il peut pas marcher il va pas chercher
son pain
et il reste chez lui donc maintenant
c'est j'ai retrouvé une liberté une
petite liberté qui me permet de
vivre tout simplement
entre l'achat de cette voiture la perte
de 30000 euros de revenus en deux ans et
de graves lésions les conséquences de
l'erreur médicale dont est victime
Guillaume gaillard sont lourdes
ça va me plaire ça aujourd'hui il a un
rendez-vous important avec son avocat et
comme toujours pour lui ça commence par
une épreuve
c'est pire que tout
[Musique]
ensemble ils veulent faire reconnaître
l'erreur du chirurgien et déterminer
l'ampleur du préjudice de Guillaume
non maintenant je pense que leur
stratégie ça va consister vraiment à
négocier sur les sommes négocier je sais
pas parce qu'on n'a pas eu de
proposition mais ça va consister à
contester chaque poste de préjudice et
essayer de minimiser le
préjudice comme la découverte Guillaume
faire reconnaître ses droits face à une
erreur médicale demande une grande
détermination c'est désespérant on
attend des mois des mois des mois des
mois en ce moment j'attends la
notification de convocation pour
l'expertise des préjudices définitifs ça
fait 6 mois que j'attends et à chaque
fois on scrute la boîte aux lettres et
on désespère qu'elle arrive un jour on
arrive à se demander si s'il faut pas
abandonner c'est reconnaître l'erreur
médicale
c'est un peu le parcours du combattant
dans la mesure où c'est de toute façon
un processus qui est long
parce que il faut d'une part démontrer
la faute il faut démontrer le lien de
causalité entre la faute et le préjudice
et surtout il faut chiffrer le préjudice
dans ce type de dossier
une durée de 4 ou 5 ans c'est
à peu près la durée moyenne
on a l'impression qu'en dehors de leurs
problèmes de santé c'est le manque de
reconnaissance de leur statut de victime
qui blesse le plus les victimes
d'erreurs médicales oui parce que les
victimes d'erreurs médicales elles vont
pas être reconnues comme un accident de
la route ou comme ou comme un crime ou
un meurtre ou quelque chose comme ça
elles ont à faire à des médecins qui
vont chercher eux aussi à défendre leur
position et à défendre leur propre
intérêts il y a corps médical qui
parfois aussi fait bloc elle fait front
c'est un langage qui est très compliqué
le langage de la médecine les médecins
ne manquent pas de justement de
s'appuyer sur leur savoir et sur leur
science pour prouver leur bonne foi à
eux donc les victimes ils ont non
seulement à faire à un univers qu'il ne
connaissent pas un langage aussi qu'il
ne connaissent pas et qui doivent
apprendre et donc c'est très compliqué à
décrypter à trouver des terrains de
dialogues autour de ça
[Musique]
Guillaume gaillard va bientôt affronter
un autre événement important un
rendez-vous médical qui pourrait bien
changer sa vie
[Musique]
alors que les médecins lui assurer que
son état n'avait pas de cause médicale
connue Éric Cano a découvert qu'il était
en fait atteint du syndrome du navire
aujourd'hui grâce à une association
Eric Ron son isolement toutes les
personnes présentes autour de la table
disent souffrir des effets secondaires
de la turbinectomie une affirmation
longtemps démentie par le corps médical
et aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus dans le
déni la seule chose c'est qu'ils sont
claires ils ne savent pas comment le
soigner ils ne savent pas comment le
soigner
l'association dirigée par Nadine bouda
se bat aujourd'hui pour faire cesser les
turbinesectomie mais aussi faire changer
le regard des médecins sur ses victimes
le but de notre association c'est
surtout faire reconnaître cette ce
syndrome mais surtout de grâce un peu de
considération arrêtez de les traiter de
fou arrêter surtout de dire que c'est du
domaine psychiatrique parce que je suis
désolé mais quand je me j'ai mal à la
jambe je ne vais pas voir mon psychiatre
et on leur demande au moins un petit peu
de considération que je veux dire un
minimum de respect pour les personnes
atteintes du syndrome du débit ils ne
sont pas fous c'est une chose ils sont
malades et à cause de qui je pose la
question
pour Eric ces réunions sont une note
d'espoir dans sa lutte pour la
reconnaissance de son statut de victime
relevé de réunir des gens en association
je me sens beaucoup moins seul à
combattre je sais qu'il sera long mais
comment on dit souvent l'union fait la
force et je pense que voilà on a besoin
d'être entouré et de faire des choses
ensemble
Drome le problème c'est quand l'état
actuel de la science il n'existe aucune
opération capable d'inverser les effets
d'une turbinectomie pire ils ont
régulièrement l'impression de ne pas
être pris au sérieux
souvent les malades pensent qu'on ne les
comprend pas qu'on les prend pour des
fous oui vous savez quand on dit j'ai
mal quelque part
on est obligé de vous croire si on vous
dit non tu as pas mal ça fait
complètement vaciller sa propre raison
la le minimum de confiance qu'on puisse
faire à quelqu'un c'est quand il vous
parle de ses sensations et qu'on valide
c'est ces sensations là or là finalement
ce qui leur est renvoyé c'est ben non
c'est pas c'est pas si important que ça
vous exagérez c'est dans votre tête
c'est parce que vous êtes déprimé que
vous augmentez cette cette douleur et ça
ça rend fou parce que ça veut dire qu'on
ne valide pas ce qu'il ressentent et ce
qu'ils éprouvent dans leur corps et et
ce sentiment là qui est peut-être le
plus douloureux chez eux en dehors de la
douleur corporelle et de l'impotence
corporelle qu'ils ont c'est que on ne
les croit pas dans ce qu'ils expriment
par rapport à leur corps
handicapé depuis la section du nerf
commandant les fonctions motrices de son
pied droit Guillaume gaillard se rend
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital Lariboisière à
Paris il a un rendez-vous dans lequel il
place beaucoup d'espoir au niveau
de l'état de mon pied au niveau du nerf
on peut plus rien faire donc on peut
essayer il y a peut-être un espoir pour
voir
si il peut reconstruire le ou les
tendons pour espérer retrouver peut-être
la motricité des doigts de pieds et le
déroulé du pied ça serait déjà un grand
pas pour moi de retrouver cette mobilité
du pied
[Musique]
allez-y poussez là je pousse pas
d'accord ce que Guillaume craint par
dessus tout c'est que le médecin juge
son pied trop abîmé pour être réopérer
après consultation le professeur Nizar
n'est ni pour ni contre il veut d'abord
que Guillaume passe une IRM pour
déterminer la faisabilité de l'opération
mais on va voir où est-ce qu'il est
sélectionné on va voir si c'est possible
de le réparer et puis ensemble on va
essayer d'évaluer le rapport bénéfice
risque entre ce qu'on décide de faire
pour le professeur Nizar
pas questionnaire a créé une situation
instable et potentiellement dangereuse
pour Guillaume il a des douleurs
d'origine neurologique et le fait de le
réopérer et susceptible de réenclencher
un mécanisme douloureux donc il faut
bien réfléchir à au bénéfices qu'on
pourrait lui amener avant de prendre le
risque de l'aggraver sur le plan des
douleurs et donc tout ça ça fait partie
d'une discussion qu'on peut avoir avec
lui
on va essayer de le faire pour le mieux
en sachant qu'on de toute façon on sera
jamais jamais jamais à la hauteur de ce
qu'il pourrait attendre malheureusement
je peux retourner le chef de service ne
refuse toutefois pas cette opération il
fera le maximum pour Guillaume c'est une
nouvelle inespéré lorsqu’il le comprend
l'émotion prend le dessus
il y a du positif
sur le papier les risques d'aggravation
de ces douleurs sont importants pourtant
Guillaume n'hésite pas un instant il
préfère se faire réopérer
je suis prêt à tenter ça quel que soit
les risques quel que soit on les
angoisses parce que les angoisses elles
seront pire en pire au fur et à mesure
que une date pouvait s'approcher mais
c'est rien par rapport aux handicap
quotidien aux souffrances quotidiennes
au fait de ne jamais pouvoir rien faire
voilà c'est je suis un handicapé qui a
l'espoir de de ne plus l'être voilà
j'aimerais bien que tous les handicapés
le même choix
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus à Guillaume
car
[Musique]